hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar physiologically relevant
tissue models using a high-throughput
organ on a chip platform I'm Nancy role
of Rosenthal of molecular devices and
I'll be moderating this session we're
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roads and
sponsored by molecular devices molecular
devices is one of the world's leading
providers of high-performance
bio analytical instrumentation software
and consumables and is dedicated to
helping customers unravel the complexity
of biological systems included within a
broad product portfolio are platforms
for high-throughput screening genomic
and cellular analysis colony selection
and biochemical assays these innovative
instruments combined with scientific
expertise enable scientists to explore
life's most important questions to learn
more about molecular devices please
visit www.netsupportdna.com the support
button found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of screen it is
now my pleasure to present today's
speakers James Huxley application
scientists molecular devices and yost
your PhD co-founder and managing
director of momentous Jane Hasley is an
application scientist for cellular
imaging at molecular devices she is
eight years experience of developing
cell based applications using image
express micro high content imaging
systems and meta Express analysis
software most recently her focus has
been on exploring the use of 3d models
such as fear of spheroids or cell
cultures in medical master gel for
studying cell viability morphological
Changez mitochondrial damage and AutoFix
aging these studies include the use of
automated confocal microscopy for live
cell time-lapse experience as well as
screening the cities in 384-well
microplates
she has a BS yes an animal science and
an MS in biology Yoshi or is co-founder
and managing director of the metas he is
a biotech engineer co-founder of four
companies with over 17 years of
executives lower-level biotech
experience in a variety of companies
including pet scan skyline Diagnostics
Korea Tech and Westberg during his 10
year research career he worked as
apposed doctor doctoral researcher at
the cube rec institutes ultra and King's
College London he holds a culotte a
master's degree in business marketing
mbm a PhD in developmental biology and a
master's degree in biology
James Hensley will now begin her
presentation thank you and welcome to
our webinar i'm jane hustla and i'm an
imaging application scientist at
molecular devices in this webinar I'll
give a quick overview of high-throughput
high content imaging and then we will
hear from Yoshi or the managing director
of momentous you also illustrate how
they scaled up their assays using
three-dimensional models and the image
express Microsystems
first in case you're not completely
familiar with high throughput imaging
I'll spend a couple of minutes giving an
overview of the workflow and the
potential applications
traditionally biologists would treat
some cells with drugs or growth factors
put them on a microscope slide after
staining them or in some way marking
their response with fluorescent proteins
or they may even be looking at
morphological changes with transmitted
light instead of just inspecting cells
through an IPS we take pictures images
to study and get a sense for whether or
not the cells reactive to the drug even
if the acquisition with a conventional
microscope is automated then what do you
do with the images you need to piece
together the image analysis separate
from your acquired plate files and
devise a way to keep the results
associated with your
images the hands-on time can be multiple
hours and it takes experience and skill
to run a successful experiment by using
an automated high content imaging system
experiments can be just as easily run on
anything from microscope slides to 1536
well plates with no compromise in image
quality this includes the ability to
image specialty plates such as the
organo plate from Mehmet Oz for
generating 3d structures the image
express micro system can be set up in a
few minutes and the biologist can walk
away while images are acquired and
analysis using the integrated software
can occur in parallel with acquisition
once numbers are generated for the
parameters of interest responsive cells
or wells can be identified statistically
analyzed plotted and conclusions drawn
since all images and measurements are
stored together in a database the burden
of keeping the data organized is removed
from the scientist and the results can
be shared within a networked company or
organization the hands-on time is
dramatically shortened due to the
automated and seamless integration of
acquisition analysis and viewing of
results mammatus is going to present how
they transitioned a 3d organ on a chip
assay from an automated stand-alone
microscope to a true high-throughput
system using their organo plate platform
there are hundreds of applications that
can be done with automated imaging
obviously these slides list just a
subset of them in these images you see
examples of Ko cultured liver cells and
fibroblasts a high magnification image
which can be used to characterize sub
cellular structures and angiogenesis
assay in a gel matrix
this slide shows more examples including
sample images of neurite outgrowths 3d
spheroid and a transgenic zebrafish we
have a great track record for solving
your biological questions with an
automated workflow the complete solution
for automated imaging begins with
reliably acquiring InFocus images of
every site and with the ability to
collect images over a wide z plane if
using a 3d sample then you will identify
objects using algorithms that are
designed for your specific assay type
you'll receive multiple measured
parameters from the image analysis that
can then use to draw your conclusions
you can use the data analysis
application we offer to pull the numbers
out of the database for generation of
ec50 curves or ic50 curves or to use it
with hit finding methods much of the
device's provides an end-to-end workflow
including each of the previously
mentioned steps starting with the image
acquisition using one of our image
Xpress system shown here at the top
image analysis is carried out using the
meta Express or medics best power core
software in the center of it all we have
the data management solution this is our
MDC store database meta express
automatically communicates with that
management solution to store images and
present them back to you for
visualization and analysis MDC store
also links the results of your analysis
to the acquired plates the data mining
software acuity Express communicates
with the database and allows processing
of the results it also allows you to
compare or combine results from multiple
plates across the screen there are
choices for your automated imager the
image express micro 4 is our newest wide
field system that is field upgradeable
to a confocal system if your needs
change the image express confocal system
is ideal for any assay that may have
high background and particularly for
many of the 3d assays either of these
instruments will allow you to acquire Z
Stax and utilize our software's 3d
analysis capabilities however meta
Express software is key to high content
imaging the software not only runs the
instrumentation but provides different
levels of analysis tools proceeding from
simple on the left to extremely flexible
on the right our turnkey solution allows
a scientist to easily evaluate images
using one of the numerous available
application modules such as
multi-wavelength cell scoring cell cycle
or neurite outgrowth custom modules
allow user to build a personalized
analysis using standard and custom
algorithms to generate specific data
such as volumes and distances within 3d
spaces all the modules can be saved and
shared between users journal macros
allow power users the ultimate control
to perform sophisticated procedures
including Hardware control to reiterate
with the correct system there's no
barrier to scaling
even 3d assays images can be seamlessly
acquired in multi-well plates visualized
and analyzed with integrated software
and then decisions can be made based on
the output you choose and this can be
done with either wide field or can focal
images now I would like to turn it over
to y'all so that he may present on human
tissue models for better therapies
please don't forget you may submit
questions at any time for us to answer
when the presentations are complete
thank you
Thank You Jane for the kind introduction
it's a great pleasure for me to present
today our company mimetics our core
product the organo plate in our exciting
organ on chip tissue and disease models
together with molecular devices first
I'm going to give you an overview of
this webinar I'm going to introduce you
momentous I'm going to spend a few words
on why we actually need phenotypic
models then I'm going to make you
acquainted with the organo plates which
is a core product and a carrier of all
of our models I'm going to show you a
couple of examples on models that we
develop in organo plates such as models
made up with cells which grow inside an
accessory matrix then we'll move on to
our unique refused to Buhl models where
a tubular epithelial endothelial cells
grows against an excess cellular matrix
and a perfusion flow of the medium goes
through the lumen of the tubules or you
combine those models we get co-cultures
either of two adjacent tubules or a tube
you'll next to cells that grow inside an
excess error matrix in order to create
higher-level complex tissue models then
I'm going to show you some of the essays
that we developed in your gamma plate
that allow you to and get interrogate
the models that grow inside the plate
and we're gonna finish up with a summary
of this webinar after the webinar there
were ample opportunity to ask any
questions
our mission is to provide human tissue
and organ models for 21st century
therapeutics we want to help to create
better medicines and personalized
therapies but of course physiologically
relevant tissue models are also crucial
for improving or fundamental insight in
tissue function and disease the
headquarters of amanda's is based in
Leiden in the Netherlands in the east of
the metal incidence kadai we have a
manufacturing site where we produce or
again a plates we have a subsidiary in
rockville maryland in the USA we have an
agent in Tokyo in Japan our model
development customers are based all over
the world so this is where we come from
2d cell culture has been around for over
a century now and it has learned us a
lot about cellular physiology animal
testing is applied a lot in drug
development unfortunately both
technologies are not very predictive
towards people they don't predict
whether a drug is going to work in
humans so we need something else
ideally we want to do the experiments on
people but there's obviously limitations
to that so what we need is a model which
is in the middle that encompasses 3d
cell culture that uses human cells and
tissues that are Co cultured allowing
the cells to interact and to create
organ and tissue functions these 3d
models should be fused for example with
an artificial blood flow they should
contain tubes and vessels and the cells
should be embedded in mexisolar matrix
mimicking the physiological environment
of cells in normal human tissues
the thing is that we need models which
are complex enough in order to allow us
to do the measurements that we want but
not too complex which would prevent us
from doing any useful experiments as
Einstein said you gotta make things as
simple as possible but not any simpler
so that's why we developed your gamma
plate you gain a plate is based on a
standard 384-well plate it can contain
up to 96 individual microfluidic
networks and because the plate is fully
compatible with high content readers
pipetting equipment another plate
reading equipment it can serve any
throughput from tens of assays up to
hundreds of thousands or even hundred
thousands of essays so this is what the
micro fluidics look like inside an
organic plate here you see a red fluid
which is the extracellular matrix which
is liquefied is entered into the device
and as you see the fluid only fills part
of the microfluidic network that is
because there's a ridge between the two
channels which is called a phase guide
it's a meniscus pinning barrier here on
the right you see the fluid coming in in
a cross-section from the right and a
meniscus will tend to align itself along
this meniscus pinning barrier or face
guide it will not jump over unless you
pressurize it once the gel is set we
have a gel filled channel here at the
bottom and the top channel can be
perfused with medium
the facelet technology allows us in a
fully passive manner to control liquids
it allows us to patent gels inside the
organo plate we can create gradients and
we can layer multiple lanes in adjacent
co-culture setups next to each other in
order to create higher leticia
functionalities the Organa plate because
it's a standard plate it's easy to use
and compatible it serves any throughput
there's no pumps needed to drive the
plate and no tubing which makes handling
actually very easy easy
the imaging is high-quality because the
bottom plate is microscope quality glass
which allows very high quality imaging
using high content readers or standard
microscopes and even high-end confocal
laser-scanning microscope and finally
because it's micro fluidics reagent
consumption is low
for example media growth factors but
also excelled in matrix gels are only
needed in small quantities so here's a
single device inside an organic plate it
takes up four wells of a 384-well plate
the first wealth serves as a gel Inlet
you could enter the liquefied gel into
the device through this well the second
well serves as a medium Inlet once you
put medium in there it will start to
flow alongside the cells in the gel
right here towards the medium outlet
actually this movie shows in a lot more
detail how it works
sorry stay Organo plate when you tip it
over you see the micro fluidics in the
reflection up to 96 individual
microfluidic networks with the gel
inlets perfusion channel and the phase
guide here we enter the liquefied gel
into the device the gel goes into the
device by capillary force and a phase
guide which is right here in the middle
prevents the gel from jumping over to
the adjacent channel once the gel is set
a virtual channel is created that can be
perfused with medium here the medium is
entered into the device the medium here
in blue would start to flow alongside
the cells in the gel remember there's no
physical barriers between the medium and
the gel channel allowing complete
interaction of nutrients growth factors
pharmaceutical compounds between the
medium and the cells in this way we can
keep cells alive for weeks or months if
you like cells may cluster together such
as repetitive parasites and if at any
point in time you can take out the plate
and imaging use image it using a high
content reader or a moving stage
microscope or a standard microscope you
get up to 96 individual data point from
a single again a plate
just a few words on perfusion too cheap
chief bump and tube free perfusion we
use a rocker platform the perfusion
rocker the fluid flow through the
tissues growing in againö plates is
driven by gravity leveling to make it go
continuously the plates are simply
placed on the perfusion rocker inside an
incubator the perfusion rocker features
time programs designed for the Organa
plate of course for evaluation purposes
you can use the standard continuous
rocker platform if you want to have full
control over the perfusion in Organa
plates you can use a perfusion rocker
here's a quick overview of some of the
models that we work on and that can be
developed inside a gamma plate our brain
models primarily use IPSC derived
neurons with astrocytes and other
accessory cells these are in athelia
models of vasculature where we create
and filiol tubules which are profused
the vasculature models can be combined
with a range of other models these are
kidney tubules primarily proximal
tubules of the kidney which serve as a
great model for example for a kidney
toxicity our cancer models will your
compan Creta cancer glioblastoma and
breast cancer liver models based on
primary parasites are PSC derived
parasites as well as a range of
well-characterized
parasites cell lines and finally our gut
models which are based on for example
Keiko 2's but also on small intestinal
gut organoids and other sources of cells
so some teacher configurations in yoga
no plate in a two-lane Agana plate we
have two lanes available where one of
the lanes can be used as a perfusion
channel with the flow of medium and the
other lane can contain an exerciser
matrix gel in which the cells grow or we
can put down an empty excess oil and
matrix gel and seat the cells as a tube
you'll against the gel where the
perfusion flow actually goes through the
tube you'll we can combine those into a
tube you'll in combination with cells
growing inside the gel in the three Lane
Organa plate which is currently not
available as an off-the-shelf product
but we will become available later this
year there's three lanes available so
there we can have a flow lane with two
different cell types growing inside two
different gels we can have the cells in
the gel in the middle lane with
perfusion of different media on both
sides creating a gradient across the
tissue wall we can for example have two
tubules on both sides of a gel in which
the cells grow
so all of the imaging I'm going to show
you has been done inside the plate we
either use confocal x' or plate readers
or if we want throughput and convenience
we use the molecular devices image
express micro and image express micro
confocal which work very well with your
gamma plate first a few examples of our
models this is an example of cells that
grow inside an extracellular matrix gel
these are induced pluripotent stem cell
derived 3d neuronal networks you're
looking at the scan through the confocal
stacks in organo plate the typical
length of a channel is about 3
millimeters the height of the channel is
120 microns so immediately see here that
there's a real 3-dimensional neuronal
network present in these plates network
formation takes place in about 24 hours
when the cells are seeded they're
rounded off but already in a couple of
hours they start to generate projections
and there's a fully functional neuronal
network after 24 hours when you seed
mature differentiated IPS see derived
neurons so here's a full line containing
neurons in a 2-lane plate we can do a
range of markers stains on cells which
are fixed inside the plate antibodies
are added inside the plate and washed
out and subsequently the models are
photographed during fluorescence
microscopy
we can also look at neuronal activity
inside these models so here we use a
calcium-sensitive dye in order to show
the spontaneous activity of these
neurons in the organo plate you can see
the flickering year which is firing
neurons inside a neuronal network in
this case as I said spontaneous activity
we can either use neuronal neural
progenitor cells or you can see mature
neurons in these plates for new genesis
it takes anything between 6 to 8 weeks
in order to differentiate into fully
mature neurons we use a range of
different sources for these cells for
example from solar dynamic section
genesis acts all a name as bio and we
can see glutamatergic GABAergic or
dopaminergic neurons and we often
co-culture them with astrocytes and
other accessory cells the neuronal
activity can be quantified inside these
plates using already developed pre setup
procedures in order to identify the
firing cells inside the plate so this
allows us to also modulate their
activity for example we have gaba
sensitive cells and we add gaba
we see that the spontaneous activity
decreases whereas when we add just
medium nothing changes
these models are perfect for example for
neurotoxicity assessment so here we add
a concentration series of methyl mercury
to the cells that have formed a neuronal
network and there you see that upon
increasing concentration of methyl
mercury the neurotics tension
dramatically goes down this can be
quantified using automated procedures
and there you get a nice graph of dose
response versus concentration of methyl
mercury or we can look at cell viability
here with three canonical neurotoxic ins
such as 2 5 hex and I own and also fan
and missile mercury and we measure
viability cell viability using standard
off-the-shelf kits now some examples of
perfused tubules inside organo plates
first how do we make a tubulin again a
plate well first we put down an empty
excess Elda matrix gel and allow it to
set then we enter the cells inside the
medium into the adjacent channel and we
allow the cells to sediment on top of
the gel you can do this by putting the
plate on its side or we can actually
have the cell sediment to the bottom and
they will grow out as well depending on
the cell type when the cells have
attached to the gel they will start to
grow and form a continuous layer along
the circumference of the channel the
perfusion flow of the medium goes
through the lumen of the tubules here's
an example of such a tube you'll yes the
gel and there's the tube you'll in this
case it's NBC case it's a dog kidney
tubules cell line and here it's obvious
that the boundary between the gel and
the cells is nothing but but XSL a
matrix gel so there's no physical
barriers between the tube you'll and the
gel which allows you to do transport
experiments
toxicity and leakage experiments but
also later on to add cells in the gel
and allow these cells to interact
directly with the epithelial tubular on
the left so this is what these cells
look like when stained with the variety
of markers here we use acetylide tubulin
in red to stain the cilia and as you see
the cilia are only on the inside of the
tube you'll and not on the outside which
is also the case for a zero one set a
one is a stain for tight junctions and
as you see is that a one in green is
also here only on the apical side of the
cells and not on the basin side here's a
blow-up which nicely slope shows two
cilia and red here and 2:01 primarily at
the apical side of the cells so these
cells are fully polarized which means
that transport going through the cells
is also directional once we have a
tubular
we can measure its sleek tightness
inside the organo plate using a real
time barrier integrity assay we do this
by entering a fluorescent dye into the
tube you'll this dye can be conjugated
to for example dextran of any size allow
you to discriminate between a large
molecule leakage and small molecule
leakage when the turbulence leak-tight
the dye will stay within the tube you'll
when it's leaky the dye will start to
migrate into the adjacent gel through
diffusion and by quantifying the
intensity of fluorescence inside the
tube you'll channel and the adjacent
channel and take the ratio of that you
get a dynamic measurement of the
leakiness or the barrier integrity of a
tubular growing inside a gana play
this is a fully unique essay because
it's time-dependent it's dynamic and you
can revisit it many times and because
it's in an organ or played it allows you
to do multiple measures measurements at
the same time so here we have the same
NBC case oh the dog kidney more or less
distal tubules saline exposed to a
concentration series of stores foreign
which is fairly well known for inducing
leakiness in kidney tubules it's toxic
to these kidney tubules and you see that
with increasing concentration of stories
pouring from left to right the tubules
start to leak first you see on the right
they start leaking first and on the left
it takes more time we can quantify this
in many ways and here you see the
leakage score over time actually showing
that at low concentrations the tubes
start to leak more slowly and at high
concentrations the leaking starts urgent
earlier we can also depict that as the
concentration of sports Taurus pouring
over the leakage score or we can
calculate an icy 15 ec50 curve and
finally which we also find often very
useful is to create a sort of
kaplan-meier curve this curve of these
tubes which means that we score the
survival of the leak-tight tubules which
also gives a very nice insight in the
effects of the compounds at different
concentrations tubular models are also
possible with a gut on a chip so in this
case we see a phase contrast image of a
kq2 tubule which is a human colon
ordinary adenocarcinoma cell line these
cells form very nice leak ty tubules
inside organo plates and we can use
these models to assess
Effects of compounds growth factors or
inflammatory factors on the leak
tightness of these tubules these are in
the figlio tubules so here you see you
tube you'll which grows against an
accelerant matrix gel which is here on
the left it doesn't light up because
it's not fluorescent and here's a tube
you'll of 200 microns wide one in a 20
micron in height and a couple of
millimeters long of you vac so human
umbilical vein and ethereal cells on the
right you see that upon staining with CD
31 this nice expression of CD 30 run
around the circumference of the cells
and also V cat urine ve cat urine is
it's nicely expressed in these cells and
also here throughput applies so this is
an experiment where we use the range of
different culture conditions medium
compositions in order to assess their
effect on the leak tightness of these
endothelial tubules so the tubules are
grown against arrange different ECMs
seeded with a range of different seeding
densities and with different medium
compositions and here you see for
example in the white box there's a lot
of leakage going on but in the red and
the blue box the tubules are fully leak
tight this can be quantified and can be
used to optimize the models and later on
to use these models as a readout for
effects on vascular leakage
when we have an endothelial tube you'll
in this case in a three-lane Organa
plate so there's a perfusion lane at the
top the perfusion Lane at the bottom and
there's a gel Lane in the middle we grew
an endothelial vessel right here in the
top lane and then we added angiogenic
factors a mix of angiogenic factors to
the bottom Lane whatever then is that
the cells start to sprout towards the
high concentration of angiogenic factors
first they start to sprout you get
fusion of capillaries and lumen
formation and finally the lumen is
widened the end result is a vascular bed
which grows through the XSL a matrix gel
here in the middle towards the adjacent
channel which is perfused when we stain
this with ve cut here inand actin it
looks like this I think a very beautiful
image with the large vessel right here
and micro capillaries with the typical
diameter of 10 to 20 microns growing
through the XSL and matrix gel towards
the other end of the channel and here we
scan through the confocal stack layers
just to show that this is a real
3-dimensional culture
so to show that these micro capillaries
are actually profused we've entered a
fluorescent dye into the blood vessel
channel which is the top channel here
and here you see that the dye flows
through the micro capillaries and enters
the channel at the bottom which is the
medium channel there we go
so these micro capillaries are actually
connecting the blood vessel channel to
the medium channel at the bottom so when
we combine different models we get
co-cultures and this is exactly what we
want
because we want these co-cultures we
want cells to interact and to create
higher tissue functionality so the first
example is these blood vessel models so
let me see this is a tubular of
parasites in the outer tubule and juvik
and ethereal cells in the inner tube so
it's a tube in a tube set up here in the
cross-section you see in green the
parasites and yep the endothelial cells
in red right here in in the center of
the green jewel this is the exact setup
of a normal blood vessel which allows
studies towards the interaction between
the parasites and endothelial cells at
the bottom we have entered vital dye
stain primary monocytes into a you
vacuole and you see they nicely show up
here and we can use these models to
assay for a monocyte attachment and also
monocyte transmigration through the
blood vessel wall into the adjacent
compartment of the organ a plate
this is a co-culture model of tutorials
on the one side we have a blood vessel
made of endothelial cells and on the
other side we have a kidney proximal
tubular here made up of our p-tech cells
which are developed by its sigma-aldrich
so there's a proximal tubulin cell line
right here in the middle is the
extracellular matrix gel which is in
this case empty here there's a variety
of stains in order to characterize these
cells the proximal tubule is stained
with ezrin the blood vessel is stained
with rfp by stable introduction of rfp
expression into the endothelial cells
this is a combination of a blood vessel
astrocytes and neurons the blood vessel
has been established in the top channel
which is profused in the middle is an
accessory a matrix gel and in the bottom
neurons and astrocytes were Co seeded
inside a gel in the bottom channel what
happens is that the extra sites start to
move through the gel towards the blood
vessel which is actually shown here
yes the sides are stained with cd44 the
neurons are stained with map 2 and the U
of X again with stabling transfected rfp
so the astrocytes have migrated into the
gel in the middle and start to move in
the direction of the endothelial cells
obviously this is a big step towards the
development of a neurovascular unit or a
blood brain barrier model so now after
these Co culture models I would like to
show you some of the essays that we have
developed inside organo plates first the
imaging readouts here at the top left we
see face contrast imaging which is
fairly obvious but it can be done in
time-lapse
over prolonged periods of time inside an
automated microscope or inside a high
content reader like the molecular
devices image express machines on the
right fluorescent microscopy which can
also be done automated inside the plate
can focal microscopy and we have a range
of different applications developed
where we do automated 3d image analysis
for example for the leakage assays as
well as food in neuronal activity assays
some of the essays are neurotoxicity
essays like the neuron extension essay
and cell viability assays which can also
be applied to a range of other cell
types of course neuronal activity assays
which I showed you this is a calcium
calcium release assay using calcium
sensitive dyes which is basically
quantified in an automated manner or
unique epithelial barrier integrity
assays where we enter a fluorescent dye
into a preformed tubular and measure the
leakiness
of the tubule by assessing the migration
of the dye into the adjacent channel and
finally I didn't show you an examples of
that our ng Genesis assays where we can
actually quantify or measure the length
of the extension of micro capillaries in
response to angiogenic factors or
anti-angiogenic factors so some of the
assay modalities I showed you some
fluorescent imaging but we can also use
fluorescence to quantify a range of
reagents inside your gonna plate such as
an album in blue assay we can use
luminescence for example in the standard
real-time glow essay to assess cell
viability we do trance epithelial
electrical resistance measurements
specifically in the blood-brain barrier
models where we do electrical
measurements in order to assess the
barrier function of epithelial or
endothelial layers in great detail and
finally there's a range of molecular
assays developed inside the organ or
plate basically by lysing the cells in
the plate and taking out lies it's
allowing us to do qpcr sequencing and
other types of molecular assays
so all of us at the end and summarizing
no matters again our plate is we think
the platform of choice to create
physiologically relevant tissues it's
easy to use it supports pump free flow
membrane free co-culture and high
quality automated imaging so here's a
quick comparison between some of the
technologies that are available to
create tissue models so there's in the
Oregon a chip world PDMS which is a
silicon rubber based device well these
devices support for example tubules but
they always require pumps and tubes in
order to grow to to to be operated their
throughput is limited there's always a
membrane between the cells preventing
the cells from real physical interaction
their format is not compatible it's not
a micro plate or anything compatible
with existing equipment imaging is often
difficult and which is very important
for pharmaceutical applications PDMS is
very well known for absorbing
hydrophobic compounds so it's generally
incompatible with pharmaceutical
compounds and finally it's very
difficult if not impossible to produce
these PDMS devices in large quantities
officially not organ on a chip but 3d
tissues can also be printed it's very
difficult to profuse these because it's
difficult to connect a printer to tissue
to a tube or a pump but you would need
tubes and pumps if you could hollow
structures such as tubes and vessels are
difficult the throughput is fairly
limited it is membrane free because you
can print cell types on top of each
other and allow them to interact the
format is generally not comparable
imaging is difficult it often requires
sectioning of the tissues materials are
compatible and mass production is
currently not available
hanging drops are a very useful tool
but they have a limited number of
applications so profusion is very
difficult if not impossible in hanging
drops chips and vegetables vessels are
not possible the throughput because both
of these plates are actually based on a
96-well plate the throughput is fairly
high co-culture Konomi can only be a
mixed Co culture there's no structured
layered Co cultures such as in your
gamma plate the format is compatible
imaging is often difficult because the
tissue can be at different heights in
the channel or in the device which makes
it difficult to focus and to find the
tissue inside these devices materials
are compatible and mass production is
available and finally just as a
comparison it's it's not real 3d cell
culture but we see it a lot-- membrane
inserts which are used to culture Mama
layers of cells on both sides of the
membrane so there's no perfusion there
no tubes and vessels the throughput can
be fairly high because there's 96-well
versions of those plates available
obviously there's always a membrane
between the cells which prevents them
from real physical interaction format is
compatible imaging is difficult
basically you have to take out the
membrane and section it to have a good
look at the cross-section of the cells
growing on the membrane materials are
compatible in this mass production we
think that your piano played as an organ
or chip device ticks all the boxes to
create physiologically relevant morals
in 3d with perfusion and co-culture
easily easy to handle with great imaging
for just an overview of our models of
cells grow inside the gel with the
perfusion channel adjacent to the cells
we develop liver models based on primary
parasites
IPSC derived repeater sites as well as
he parasite cell lines I showed you our
neuronal models towards brain models
where we can create three-dimensional
neuronal networks inside the plate we
work a lot with organoids which are
algae of five plus organoids such a
small intestinal organized but other
also other types of organ weights are
profuse tubular models where the tubule
is seeded against a preset XSL a matrix
gel in the adjacent channel such as the
kidney proximal tubule models the
vasculature models and ethereal tubules
as well as the gut models and we combine
those into co-culture models where we
have two tubules in our kidney clearance
model so there's a proximal tubule as
well as a blood vessel a co culture of
astrocytes and neurons with an N filial
to Buell and this is the example of a
tube in a tube setup I showed you with
endothelium in the center of a parasite
trivial at the medes were convinced that
these Organa plate based models are the
next generation of phenotypic models
they can capture the complexity of
tissues by having adjacent Co culture of
different cell types incorporating
vessel structures which are perfused
allowing full interaction between the
cells and a free choice of excess Elder
matrixes we can capture disease
phenotypes in these models by taking
primary patient derived cells or
obviously derived cells from a variety
of genetic backgrounds we can enter
reagents challenges into the models in
order to recreate disease phenotype
and use many other methods and obviously
we can enter pharmaco into these models
to assess their effects and finally by
using either IPSC derived cells stem
cells organoid cells or primary cells we
can capture the differences between
individuals
we started off applying these models
primarily in the preclinical field
looking into tox transport and other
types of assays but over the last two
years we be moving towards primary and
secondary screens by developing disease
models and specific models which are set
up for screening of compound effects at
the medes we're also working on
personalized medicine applications where
we enter patient derived cells and
tissues into these devices in order to
assess the effects of pharmaceutical
compounds before we actually administer
a drug to a patient
so this is a list of some of the
publications on organo plate based
models you can have a look at them in
your own time or you can visit the metas
calm weather also listed finally I would
like to thank you for your attention and
for your time and it would also like to
thank molecular devices again for
collaborating on this great webinar and
of course I would like to thank them a
meta steam of about 42 biologists
engineers and supporting colleagues that
were all crucial to develop these
exciting new technologies and models you
can contact Bob for Agana plates
Remco for projects or you can contact me
and i'm here with my colleague orietta
lumps to answer any of your questions
thank you dr. Yuri for your presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply enter them in
the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window
dr. Yuri or I will answer as many
questions as time permits so I'm going
to start off with the first question
that's four for me and I don't know if
you're seeing in a slide first question
is all right so it was asked how long it
takes to acquire images in a 3d format
in a 384-well plate and also another
question was how long it takes to
analyze those images so I will say that
if you're doing a single plane in a 384
well plate with two colors it takes
about ten minutes to read the plate this
is using our confocal image Express
micro if you're doing 3d say five planes
two colors it's around 23 minutes to
acquire the entire plate now analysis
can occur at the same time as
acquisition and depending on the
complexity of your analysis it could
take the same amount of time as it takes
to acquire the images or if you have a
complex 3d analysis with this kind of
pertains to some of the other questions
where you're looking at volumes and such
then it could take longer of course but
how about power core with the power core
software using parallel processing you
can improve your analysis time by up to
10 times ok now I'm going to ask a
question for for doctor you're a someone
wants to know what quality control you
use to ensure repeatability of the cell
organization in the various wells of the
Organa plate
thank you we basically used a range of
methods also depending on the type of
model that we set up so the simplest
quality control is checking the face
contrast images
after seeding or before a saying second
for the tube models we actually often
use a leakage test before we actually
start to expose the cells in order to do
the leakage assay so we pre-established
leak tie tubules before we start to to
use them so depending on the application
there's a range of assays that we can
apply before we actually do the real
measurements but usually there
image-based
because that's the best way to get into
the Organa plate without disturbing the
the cultures okay thank you another
question I have is yes when you say 3d
image analysis are you doing analysis on
the reconstituted volume to extract the
volume measurements that's correct
and also there it depends on the
application so sometimes it's sufficient
just to do a max projection of the the
image stack and basically look at the
image but in many cases we analyze the
volume and and use that in a more or
less automated set up to to quantify the
signals inside that volume rather than
doing and honor on a max projection or a
flat projection of the of the image okay
and dr. Yuri when I talked a little bit
about how long it takes us to read 3d
objects but someone wants to know how
quick it is to image the organoids in
the Organa plate and how many organoids
per Lane are we talking about so in
terms of organoids per Lane it's it's
usually in the range of about say 10
organoids to 20 organoids in a single
ray length you can see them more densely
or less densely depending on the type of
readout if you have swelling for example
they can really swell up and then the
types of readouts also determine the
amount of time that it takes to do it
so for example for the swelling I say
the imager now it is fairly straight
forward so we do an edge detection we
basically simplify the image
so you see the organoids as a as a
cutout in the image there you only need
a 2d image which is basically converted
into almost a bit in that bitmap type
image and then we do a qualification for
the size of the the swelling organoids
if it's about higher level
quantification or higher level analysis
you really need to take the confocal
stacks and do a 3d representation of the
full culture so there the imaging
usually takes anything between a couple
of minutes to 10 minutes per individual
well depending on the optical resolution
of the C stack for for flat imaging like
you answered before actually it can be
really quick we can do a full plate in
less than 5 minutes if necessary okay
and then a little bit to answer my
question pleasures so what are the
differences between doing the assays on
the your automated microscope setup that
you showed versus the molecular devices
imager well there's a couple of big
differences I think the first thing is
that generally the speed of a high
content reader like the image Express is
it's much faster than than any of the
open moving stage automated microscopes
that we know of which is a very
important thing the full operation of
the machine is automatic so also
changing colors etc you can you can also
automate putting the plate into the
Machine and I think the most important
part that that's the software package
which is associated with with the image
express that allows us to do almost
fully automated image analysis on either
flat images or image stacks which saves
a tremendous lot of time and which is
basically hard to get for a standard
automated microscope so I think that
would answer the question yeah that's
great and thank you people for taking
the poll that was coming up
also another question was how long can
you image cells for the live cell assay
and you may be able to answer in your
experience your but I can tell we've had
customers reports they're doing five-day
assays keeping the cells alive in their
plates
in the instrument that's equipped with
some environmental control and if you
have anything to add you can go ahead I
don't know if you've done long-term life
cell assays in side image Express yes we
did
but we don't leave them that long in
inside the machine the five days that
you mentioned is it's obviously true
what we want to revisit cultures we
usually put them in the incubator and
then put them back at regular intervals
into into the Emmis express and that
allows us to do you know some really
long-term essay so like some of the
neuronal cultures it could take up to
two months before you get neuronal
differentiation and we follow that using
images imaging and also some of the
tumors that we culture I think the
record at this point is just over six
months of a single single tumor growing
inside and oregano plate it's a table
stoma tumor and we regularly image that
tumor over regular intervals by putting
it into the incubator at interval times
and it looks like we're just about out
of time so we still have several
questions I think Yost and I will
probably answer these people
individually if possible I don't see
something that's really general and so
that's what I think we'll do I would
like to now thank for one thing ma'amed
us for their presentation I think it was
amazing and let everybody know that this
webinar will be available for viewing
we're lab routes we'll send you an email
a follow-up email and you can view this
and share it with your coworkers
within two weeks for sure and it'll be
available until for three months until
June or something alright so thank you
very much for attending and we hope to
see you at our next webinar